was your path to becoming a professional
screenwriter the path that you thought
it was going to be going back to even
before you applied for film school yes
and just the vision of whatever it was
yes in your old seeing this is where I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be the next
Cassavetes or whatever yeah and then you
know time moves on and and was it was it
in line with that you know because
people think it's going to be this no
it's never will be MW no it's the
romanticized image no and then it's more
of a craftsperson
job it's a career but I'd look at it as
a job it is my job and I'm blessed to
have the job and I'm blessed to be
working I really like to work and I take
as much work as I can and turn down
things that I don't like or can't do but
it's nice to be in a place where
producer calls you and says are you
available I've also been in a place
where you turn in your thing and go am I
good enough you know and you wait and
they say and they six months later oh I
didn't read it yet you know I mean which
is the norm so whatever level of the
business you're working at to be have
any type of success I've also realized
is an amazing thing it's hard and many
people can look down at you unless
you're the highest echelon at the a-list
and say well if you're not that then I'm
not impressed by what you do it's like
okay I get it you've never really
struggled to get one thing made so you
wouldn't say that to someone who's been
slogging away the 10 year overnight
success like I said it was six years out
of film school six years before I had my
first professional job that I was later
fired from quickly you know and then
seven years from my spec to go through
all the wrong people and and the respect
almost won the nickel fellowship and all
these adventures with that one speck now
I wrote other ones right but but in it
for it to finally end up you know me
sitting on the set first day of filming
going wow this has been seven years you
know and every every script and project
has its own journey but sure out of film
school I thought that they were gonna
hand us you know our diploma and our
three picture deal which is the joke
where you just bill of course I'll be
working you know and maybe is a PA which
I never did because I
you know I knew how to make films I
didn't want to spend 18 hours a day not
writing so I worked in restaurants as a
waiter because then I could always write
you know that's a no I mean going
through college but then you settle into
a place where you finally are at
whatever level you are and have the
players that you are hired you know the
people that you know and do I still want
to get to higher levels absolutely but
no one can take away my ability to write
and create projects you know so that's
the thing so the next step for me would
to be moving into more of a producing
aspect directing I've enjoyed but I
don't I would have probably pursued it
out of film school you know and I really
liked the fact that as a writer you can
go anywhere like I mentioned I was in
Italy last year for six weeks and I was
writing a screenplay so if you have a
laptop an internet connection
you know you can write anywhere but a
director needs a film crew and a big you
know I have some friends who work two
years on a movie directing it you know I
mean from beginning to end I mean that's
a big big endeavor and I like the fact
of of being able to be mobile you know
and work and maybe do more you know this
last year I've had six movies written
you know so I mean it's it's I couldn't
direct six movies I don't think in here
yeah it's so expensive yet to it that's
that's a great thing about the writing
is that even though sometimes they're
underappreciated it's it's the heartbeat
of the movie and it's it's you know
gonna be on vacation or you can be doing
something else and yeah righty but in
terms of like you grew up in Southern
California I did so I wonder does that
taint people and not in a bad way but I
mean in terms of the vision of what a
career looks like versus someone that's
you know yeah in another state it's
weird because in some ways it never
seems such a weird when when my friend
and I were making movies as a kid it
never seemed such a weird thing that we
were filmmakers because they were
filming movies on our block you know
outside the biggest TV shows were right
up the block you know and
mónica they used to film everything
there and so we were like oh now if I
was living in a small city somewhere it
might be so impressive like oh or I
could never be a film because it's so
such a big enormous dream it was right
outside our front door so we were like
huh okay in a good way or bad because
you don't know if you're ever gonna be
able to do it you know and achieve a
career and sustain that so it has I
think the wide-eyed dreamer is still
inside and I need that as a kid but then
you grow up and you realize the
realities of a business you know
filmmaking is is a craft and it's it's
you know but it's a business you know no
one wants to spend millions of dollars
and lose their money on your idea you
know what I mean it's a business
unfortunately but if you can work in it
and keep you know as an artist and and
some are blessed to be an artiste you
know an auteur and others are people who
get to work
you know and you know if I'm working in
the film business I'm a happy person
you know you think you realize the
amount of time spent alone at a computer
at a desk I mean I realize you could be
in a cafe writing sure and for a lot of
people that does work but do you think
that you realize the and and being bound
by this calendar the calendar that said
okay this is do and I need this done by
this date and I can't deviate from that
and you have a you know in school or a
college you have a report or whatever do
you know there's there's due dates for
everything
but that that made it seem more like a
job which in in the past it was a
romanticized like oh my specs I'll sell
it and there'll be some weird thing that
happens where you won't have to work so
hard because you did the work right you
sold the spec with all the rewrites and
all the possibilities that could happen
then when you start working in the
business you realize all the
possibilities that do happen and you're
like oh wow it's sort of knocks down the
shimmer of this romanticized you know
driving with this you know I had a
convertible at one time
why that go ahead no it was a 1964 Buick
which is beautiful and I would drive up
the coast but I was like you know
there's you know driving on this the lot
and all this stuff that you dream of you
know but then you still have to do the
work mm-hmm and like I said I worked
with a lot of actors back in the
restaurant days who didn't want to do
the work they loved you know I'm an
actor you know I'm brooding in this are
you taking classes well no and went on
this audition cuz I have a good look
you're like oh so you just don't want to
do the work you know or you think it's
that easy so yeah it's it's changed I
think the perception I think once you
work in something we have this outside
perception that many people might have
of how oh how amazing is to be a writer
you're like it is but as a writer take
the Hollywood element out it's it's you
know it's a grind you got to write you
know you got to come up with stuff all
35 scripts I think about I go how did I
channel that many stories through this
body into these things I mean then I go
there won't be any others in the well
how could there be well that's your job
as a writer right to come up with
another story to come up with another
you know I mean that's the beautiful
part about going back to the well and
having it be full of stuff and that's
where you're living comes into play your
experiences and living in an authentic
life where your lowey's like observing
and doing things because it's your
homework as a screenwriter to do that
because you don't want to go back to
your well and have it be empty that's
when it's vents when you have your
passion dries up and you're like I got
nothing to say I got what am i doing you
know and you you shrink and you just
disappear you know so I think also while
you're trying to pursue your career you
have to live a an interesting life and
do things that are interesting and meet
interesting people and you know have it
all relate back to your screenwriting
because it does it's your job to live an
interesting authentic life and I think
that helps your work
you